tonight's opening face off brought to you by
Theodore Robbins for Jake Brank and Francis
shiron Are the referees Travis Tumi and James
Tobias so it'll be interesting to see how they
handle his subtraction at least in the faceof
circle it's weird isn't it no patre berser on no
Cree look out here here's a breakaway shorthanded
Jake de Bros in hit the goal post so Gibson living
right early on as the Bruins very nearly convert
short-handed here's a look at that play where de
brusk is Off to the Races and he had John Gibson
measured had him beaten on the stick side but it's
off the dead center of the goal post and Pops
right back out just after that Charlie Coyle
gets it to De brus puts it on net from 100 feet
away and Gibson handles that silverberg caught on
the back checked by coil across the line for Max
Jones he just missed great speed on on the entry
for Jones and reek tied up there bakan and goes
off the glass away to Center Ducks two-on one
here comes zis he's got Terry with him he'll take
the shot and it's swept away byar he didn't cover
it zigis tried to flip it over the net to Terry
and very nearly caught allar Terry Trevor zis
away it looked like it was going to be a two-on
one but they didn't have a lot of speed zis from
a sharp angle but this pass to Terry forces Omar
to make a real good stop Bo TR Terry it doesn't
show it really in slow motion but those are some
quick hands so for the third time in this opening
period the Bruins on the power play Gibson makes
a save but can't cover the rebound maram puts it
on the doorstep bounces away from Van reight
and zaka knocked down at the moment of truth
under a minute to go they move it around and a
one time Blast from Maran glances off of Gibson
the Bruins were really exploiting the middle of
the ice on their power play they kept moving it
into that slot area had a couple of good looks
be interesting to see how Greg Cronin and his
group take that away Terry's pass went off a
skate came right to the front of the net Mavis
trying to shovel it through the goal creaks and
a good save by mikov who got a skate on it got it
to the net rebound for McTavish and Omar stopped
that good Puck recovery against strome room for
mnov his shot blocked on the way number one unit
knocks that puck down with the left foot keeps it
alive and just Zips it down to the creaser and
mcabs just tries to over MC tow drags it around
Trent Fredrick but then he ran into Mitchell right
in front of the bench ducks on the rush and they
get a good look they're best to the period Mavish
turned away byar the Bruins win the draw floated
on net by ly Holm easily punched to the corner
by Gibson but recovered by the Bruins McTavish
with a good stick knocks it away in the slot he
falls down pot got it in front and shatton Kirk
denied by Gibson bad turnover in behind the net
Mavis head up but he's he's kind of gliding he's
not taking strides and as a result there's
the turnover was shaton Kirk that snuck down
from the left point and forc John Gibson make a
good stop Maran curls it into the middle of the
ice stretch pass poer knock behind the defense
Fowler tries to Mark him he drops it off high
short side pit B zaka fought off by Gibson during
an Anaheim power play in that second period and
he has not come out for the third so Jake Brink
and the linesmen going old school here as just
one referee and two linesmen to begin the third
period didn't get it out of the Zone De brus Long
Shot def Flex behind the net and there's ly Holm
with it tracked by Troy Terry all the way across
a lot of room for geeky and that shot turned
away that's a great shot a great stop by John
Gibs and geeki who's just inside the faceof
dot and again it's the positioning of Gibson
watch the push off the left skate to get him out
beyond the top of the goal crease the battle for
the rebound is finally controlled by vrono good
play by McTavish to keep it alive thrown behind
the net to vrono short side and a big save by elar
and the referee taking a close look to make sure
that's not in the net good attack play here as
Ryan stro dishes it back to vrono he gets a one
timer away and allmark was falling back into the
net but he he still managed to keep his balance
but this is close that puck drops down and you
can see V Toronto is just hacking away at it
the horn sounds over at the scorers back Johnston
supports has the puck in his feet along the boards
Lon dislodges it zis out there with him got it
back to the line LOM across room for Fowler pass
to zigas put it right into the goal crease kicked
out by Omar this game all of a sudden opens up a
little hectic down around both gold creases and
both gold tenders forc to make good [Applause]
stops Gibson peels it off for Min
Yakov Here Comes McTavish two onone
with stro great pass big save rebound
score Mason [Applause] [Music] Mavish
[Music] we promised you a goal we finally got
watch the play that Frank Rono makes chops it
into the middle McTavish blows past P knock finds
ran stro and he's there for the rebound go to the
front of the net and good things happen here's the
give and go great pass across by the way to stro
is a good stop by olark but lyol can't prevent
Mason McTavish from just sliding that rebound
home for McTavish is second of the season and the
ducks have the lead one [Applause] nothing this
one sent wide by Leon High in the zone Ricochet
is off the end boards and ahead to brust Pops it
into the middle Ian Mitchell the defenseman feeds
it ahead a little bit of trouble for Morgan geeky
threw it in front and patress scores first NHL
goal for 19-year-old Matthew pois from Brett
Leon and gets his stick down on the ice Puck is
going to go in behind Ilia leushin lbushkin had
just spun around so he did not see the pass
from geeki and it goes right through his legs
onto the Stick of pis and John Gibson was trapped
on the short side goal post could not get back in
time now the rookie spinning gas around
it's still in his skates as he brushes it
to the line ly Holm across for Carlo de brusk
shot rebound score pess again the rookie has
two the brus who has been impressive to me
John as one of the best Bruins not not only
does pus get the rebound Bruins two ducks
one motoring into the Zone McTavish drops
it off scrome pulls the trigger Lively rebound
off of allmar cleared Away by the Bruins Terry
brushes it back zis throws it into the slot
Terry picks it up from behind the net Slips
Away in front just out of the reach of zigris
back to the line Gus's blast saved by allar he
covers [Applause] [Music] up and the Ducks
control mov to the middle he shot creates
a rebound nobody can get to it until it's
poked to the boards zis and again to the
line mikov great keep but his shot knock
down Maran the other way give and go empty
now and the Ducks deserved a much better
fate tonight but now they're down two with
only two and a half to play going to battle
off the face off mov tried to get it across
it was Charlie foil made a real nice play
to block that attempt at pass got it over
to Maran as now under 10 seconds remain shaton
Kirk will hold it behind the net de brus gives
allar a punch and the Bruins have a 3 to
one victory over the Ducks here tonight